Prof: Good morning.
We can continue with our
subject of Asiatic cholera.
And I thought we could perhaps
frame that discussion by
reminding you that in the 1990s
the Nobel Prize winning
microbiologist,
Joseph Lederer,
coined a term,
"emerging diseases."
He used it to describe
infectious diseases that are
previously unknown,
at least as sources of human
infection,
and emerge, as it were,
for the first time to infect
human beings.
These are diseases--in our own
day we can think of Ebola or
Lyme's disease,
SARS, or of course,
most importantly,
HIV/AIDS.
Often the press--which seems,
I would argue,
to suffer chronically from
historical amnesia--
it often treats the appearance
of new infections as something
unprecedented,
unnatural, that never happened
before.
But the reality is that Charles
Darwin was correct.
We live in the midst of a
constantly evolving microbial
world in which the microbes have
an inherent advantage because of
the frequency of their
mutations,
and the extremely brief length
of a microbial generation,
compared with a human one.
So, new diseases have always
been emerging and appearing.
And Asiatic cholera is a good
example of what we might--
though let's be mindful,
it would be historically
anachronistic--
we might call it a great
emerging disease of the
nineteenth century.
There is a scholarly debate on
whether cholera had long existed
on the Indian subcontinent,
and whether it went back for
centuries or not.
It clearly, by the early
nineteenth century,
had an endemic home on the
Indian subcontinent,
and particularly the area here
in the delta of the Ganges and
Brahmaputra Rivers.
That's that area.
There are accounts of diseases
in various writings that are
suggestive of cholera well
before the nineteenth century.
But that particular debate is
exotic for our purposes,
and what we want to know is
that by the early nineteenth
century it was endemic in the
Indian subcontinent.
But it was unknown elsewhere in
the world,
until it burst into a major
epidemic in 1817 that then
escaped India and began its
devastating international
career,
reaching Europe for the first
time in 1830.
Cholera for the nineteenth
century was something new,
something never before
experienced,
and that helps to explain a
good part of the reaction to the
populations that were first
afflicted by it,
as the "great
cholera,"
we should remember,
was the great feared disease of
the nineteenth century.
We've already seen that plague
was the most dreaded disease,
from the fourteenth century
through the seventeenth.
And we know that smallpox
succeeded it in that role in the
eighteenth.
Cholera, though not the great
killer of the nineteenth
century, was the most feared
affliction.
It was feared for a number of
reasons: its extremely sudden
appearance;
its exotic and unfamiliar
character;
the agonizing and gruesome
nature of its symptoms;
its high case fatality rate;
and its predilection for adults
in the prime of life,
rather than children.
It's revealing that a great
deal of the discussion
surrounding the early
experiences with cholera
revolved around the question of
whether this was,
in fact, the return of the
plague.
Some of the names that were
given to cholera capture the
fear it inspired.
It was known in all kinds of
ways.
If you read the medical
journals of the nineteenth
century,
and the press,
you see it was called Asiatic
cholera,
cholera morbus,
perhaps very scaringly
cholera asphyxia;
it was known as "the
gypsy," "the
monster,"
"blue cholera"
and "King Cholera,"
among other names as well.
Now, since the nineteenth
century was an era of acute
social tensions,
it was, as you all know,
marked by a series of
revolutions,
and is often dubbed the
rebellious century for that
reason.
You know about the revolutions
of 1830,
the revolutionary wave of 1848
to 1849,
across the continent,
when there were something like
fifty revolutions within a
two-year period.
Italian independence,
the Paris Commune.
One could go on.
But due to the fact that
cholera frequently accompanied
those events,
and indisputably did heighten
social and political tensions,
it used to be common to
speculate about whether the
passage of cholera across Europe
was itself a contributory factor
in the coming of revolutionary
outbursts.
By now it's pretty clear that
the causal chain actually worked
the other way around.
In other words,
the outbreak of revolution,
war and social order created
conditions for cholera to
thrive.
Cholera moved,
I would argue,
in the wake of revolution,
rather than triggering it.
So, cholera,
if it didn't cause the
revolutions that marked the
nineteenth century--
there has been in recent
literature a swing of the
pendulum in a different
direction,
with a view sometimes expressed
that cholera was dramatic,
yes, but not a lasting
influence on the history of the
West after all.
Some would say that it was
dramatic,
that it led to all sorts of
short-term sound and fury,
but in the long-term,
that argument runs,
its legacy was small,
and clearly nowhere near the
order of magnitude of plague and
smallpox.
Well, we'll be deciding among
those conflicting views.
But before we can assess them
properly,
we should look in our usual way
at the etiology of cholera,
at its epidemiology,
its symptoms and its course in
European and North American
history.
Then we'll be in a better
position to judge its impact.
There were seven pandemics of
Asiatic cholera,
the first in 1817 to '23,
which was an Asian event.
The second pandemic was in the
1830s and affected Asia,
but also Europe for the first
time, and North America.
The third pandemic of 1846 to
'62, afflicting Asia,
Europe, again North America.
The fourth pandemic,
from '65 to '75,
again it was global.
The fifth pandemic,
from 1881 to '96,
mainly a matter of Asia and
Europe.
The sixth pandemic of 1899 to
'23, again primarily an Asian
and European event.
And then the seventh pandemic,
from 1960 onward,
that went through Asia,
South America and Africa.
The last pandemic,
however, has been milder and
less virulent,
with a new biotype,
the El Tor, which is less
dramatic and less fatal than
classic cholera,
which is our subject,
and which was the form of
cholera from the first pandemic
through the sixth.
The endemic home of cholera,
as I've said,
was the Indian subcontinent,
in the delta,
the Ganges and Brahmaputra
Rivers.
And it was confined there until
a number of developments enabled
it to spread.
The bacterium that causes
cholera is extremely delicate
and doesn't travel so easily.
So, it required a number of
factors that enabled the disease
to move beyond its original area
of endemicity.
What were some of those?
One was colonialism itself,
which meant large-scale troop
movements and increasing contact
between the subcontinent and the
outside world.
The increase in trade did the
same thing in terms of
increasing contact.
Then there was the transport
revolution, which was very
important.
Because, as I said,
cholera doesn't travel so well
over extended periods of time,
and it was the railroad,
the steamship and,
later in the century,
the Suez Canal,
that radically reduced the
traveling time from the
subcontinent to other parts of
the world.
Another major factor was
religious pilgrimages and fairs
in the Indian subcontinent
itself.
And very most especially,
from the European perspective,
a very important factor was the
Hajj, the voyage of pious
Muslims to Mecca.
Now, that cholera afflicted
Europe and North America in the
nineteenth century wasn't
therefore a matter of chance.
Epidemic diseases exploit
features of societies that are
social, political and economic
and environmental.
Cholera is spread,
as we'll see,
exclusively by the oral fecal
route;
that is, it's ingested by food
and water contaminated by feces.
And it requires,
therefore--it clearly is among
the diseases,
certainly that we've examined
so far,
cholera is clearly different
from plague and smallpox in that
it's much more a social disease;
that is to say,
a disease that has a clear
predilection for poverty and for
pathologies of social and
economic life.
Cholera thrived on chaotic,
rapid, unplanned urbanization,
with its overcrowding and
teeming slums,
with inadequate and insecure
water.
This continues to be true with
cholera in our own day.
It thrives on substandard
housing, on inadequate and
inappropriate diet.
It has a predilection for port
cities, which are usually the
first places to be affected.
This reminds us perhaps of
plague a little bit.
Places in Europe,
like Marseilles,
Hamburg, Valencia,
Naples were among the first and
most frequently to be afflicted.
Cholera thrives also on filth
and the absence of sewage
systems.
Cholera is, among many things,
a disease of poverty.
Cholera also had a pronounced
predilection for the poor,
as I've said.
And in that way it exacerbated
social tensions.
Cholera, as I said,
was associated with
revolutions, though it followed
rather than provoked them.
You can see that in the revolt
in Poland in 1830,
the revolutions of 1848 to '49,
when cholera is often part of
the movement of troops to
repress the revolutions,
rather than being a factor in
their cause.
It was conditioned by the 1860s
war between Austria and Prussia
as well.
Well, what about the disease
itself?
The pathogen is this,
the Vibrio cholerae,
which was discovered by Robert
Koch in 1883,
helping to establish the germ
theory of disease.
Now, this--we'll note the
flagellum or tail of the
Vibrio,
that plays an important role in
the human gut,
and we'll talk about that in a
moment.
Its transmission you know
pretty well because of your
reading for this week of John
Snow,
On the Mode of Communication
of Cholera. You know that
this is one of the foundational
texts of epidemiology,
where he did a brilliant
epidemiological job of detective
work by finding the famous Broad
Street pump--
that the people who drank the
water from that particular pump
were the ones who fell ill and
took the disease back to their
homes.
Snow did a good job of
establishing that cholera then
was ingested in water,
primarily;
although it was also
demonstrated later that
shellfish and vegetables--that
is food--contaminated with fecal
matter can also play a role.
This was--that's John Snow--and
this is the famous Broad Street
pump that made such an important
moment in the history of medical
science and epidemiology.
Though it's important to
remember that--
it may seem odd to you as you
read this book and look at all
of Snow's evidence--
to remember that in fact it
failed to convince the medical
profession at the time,
by and large.
There was a big debate about
whether cholera was contagious
or not.
We'll be coming back to that
debate and the reasons for and
against.
But one of the things was that
John Snow was unable to
demonstrate an actual mechanism.
There was something in the
water, but he wasn't able to
establish what it was,
and therefore he didn't provide
a convincing mechanism.
And for people who thought that
probably it was some chemical
factor,
if it was anything--that Snow's
biggest chance of making an
argument was that it would be
something chemical.
Well, if so--and remember this
was London--
if there was some sort of
chemical in the River Thames,
surely it would be infinitely
diluted,
and so how would it be possible
that this chemical substance,
if that's what it was,
was spreading the disease?
So, there was a big debate
about whether Snow was actually
right.
It was proved later in the
century conclusively that he
was.
But it's important to realize
that for a long time his writing
was very far from convincing the
international medical
profession.
That didn't happen until the
1880s and 1890s.
Well, what were some of the
factors in the transmission of
cholera in the West?
We've talked about trade and
the transport revolution.
We've talked about pilgrimages.
We've talked about the
strategic role of seaports,
where once again,
as in the case of plague,
it would be imported.
The bacterium would gain access
to the municipal water supply,
and there would also be the
danger of swimming,
or of eating shellfish that fed
on sewage,
especially if the custom was to
eat it raw.
The disease would then spread
along inland transportation
networks.
We've said too that cholera was
a disease of urbanization,
and of a defective urban
infrastructure,
without sewage systems.
And remember,
in the nineteenth century,
waste in European cities was
predominantly thrown into the
streets,
where there would be a seepage
downward into tank wells;
that people would then drink
the water and its bacterial
bounty.
Remember, too,
that that many of the cities of
Europe--
Naples, that you're reading
about, but Paris too,
and many others--were
surrounded by vegetable gardens,
and the vegetables would be
brought into the city and
consumed by the population.
But in the growing of the
vegetables,
use was made of urban sewage,
which was collected and
transported to the vegetable
gardens outside the city,
and then the sewage was used as
fertilizer--
it was good not to waste
anything--and the plants then
grew in human sewage,
and then the vegetables were
brought back to town.
So, we have a wonderful way for
the bacterium to make an
excellent roundtrip between the
hinterland and the city itself.
This was the practice of sewage
farming, which was extensive
throughout the West.
And there was a good trick that
market farmers knew very well,
market gardeners,
which was that if you had an
open sewer--
and there were many--if you
dipped your head of lettuce,
on the way to market,
into the sewer,
then the ammonia from human
urine would make the vegetables
look fresh,
for sale in the market.
So that was a good little trick
that you might want to remember.
In any case,
overcrowding was also another
important factor in this.
And I just want you to remember
housing conditions.
These are the fondachi
in Naples that you've been
reading about.
And you can see that this is a
place, if you use your
imagination, that's a wonderful
place for a cholera epidemic.
Not only the fact of lack of
sewage and wells,
but the fact that it's really
dark,
and it's overcrowded,
and people, lots of people,
live in a single room,
and that single room is used as
the sickroom,
the sleeping room.
It's a place also where food
supplies are stored,
and with little opportunity to
have clean hands.
And remember that the Vibrio
cholerae is spread through
fecal matter.
But the point is that in these
conditions,
and in the dark,
it's very difficult to see,
and therefore it's difficult to
know when contamination was
actually taking place.
Or, moving from Naples--these
are streets in Nottingham,
in England, where cholera also
caused a couple of major
epidemics, for similar reasons.
And the waste matter was simply
hurled into streets like this.
And in the center of the street
would be the gutter,
which would carry human waste
as well.
Another source of contamination
is flies, which carry the
cholera bacterium with them.
The clothing of victims--that
is, the bed linen,
the mattresses and so
forth--were also sources of
infection,
and laundresses were people who
were particularly likely to fall
victim.
And remember that cholera
spread also by asymptomatic
carriers.
It was possible to be
spreading- shedding the
bacterium without exhibiting
symptoms.
Well, how was the--what were
the symptoms of cholera?
And that I'm going to argue,
the symptoms,
the symptomatology,
is an important factor in the
social response to this dreadful
disease,
and it's captured by such terms
as "blue cholera,"
"cholera asphyxia,"
and "the monster."
This is a picture of a
representation of a cholera
victim in the agony of the
disease, and this is an
imaginative idea of how
overwhelming it is.
This is a cholera patient about
to be overwhelmed by the disease
itself.
Well, the bodily defenses
against cholera are numerous.
The saliva in the mouth was an
important defense.
The digestive juices of the
stomach are acidic and tend to
kill the bacterium when it's
ingested.
So, it's quite possible to
ingest cholera bacteria without
falling victim to the disease
itself.
But there are a number of
important variables that
condition what happens next.
One would be how great-
extensive the infective dose
actually was;
how much did you swallow?
The diet that you're living on
is important because such foods
that the poor,
in particular,
lived on in European cities,
as ripe and overripe fruit and
vegetables--
in other words,
the poor were likely to buy
goods that were beginning to
degenerate and deteriorate,
because they'd be marked down
in price,
and those would be the goods
that the poor would live on.
And this meant that they often
suffered from dire real
illnesses,
and those reduced the digestive
time,
and therefore deprived the
stomach of its defensive
capacity to protect you by the
acidity of the digestive juices.
And the consumption of raw
fruit, for example,
would be especially common in
the summer months.
Another factor would be the
general health of the person who
was exposed to the disease.
Let's suppose that you've eaten
a very large infective dose,
and it passes successfully
through your stomach,
into the small intestine.
What happens next?
Well, there's an incubation
period.
It can be as short as a few
hours.
And this too was important in
the social history of cholera,
and could last up to three
days.
The site of infection is the
small intestine.
There the flagellum,
at the tail of the bacterium,
that we've seen,
propels the Vibrio,
and it attaches itself to the
intestinal wall.
Ironically, there the immune
system of the body is usually
capable of killing the
bacterium.
But when it--as the bacterium
dies, it releases a very
powerful toxin,
an enterotoxin,
that's one of the most powerful
poisons in nature.
And its effect on the
intestinal wall is to cause it
to work in reverse;
that is, to drain fluid from
the bloodstream into the bowel,
and from there it's expelled.
So, the mechanism by which
cholera kills first of all,
and predominantly,
is a sort of hemorrhaging to
death,
in which the blood serum loses
its fluidly massively--
liters can be expelled in a
matter of a few hours--
and the patient hemorrhages to
death,
in effect, losing its blood
plasma and excreting what are
called the famous rice-water
stools,
and the patient goes into
hypovolemic shock.
Nineteenth-century physicians
said--this is no longer a
fashionable term today--but they
described cholera as going
through two major stages.
The first was called the algid
stage, which was the time of
high drama and terror,
which had a sudden onset,
without warning.
This was part of the social
tensions that were generated by
cholera.
In other words,
you could be seized suddenly
with this dreadful disease out
in a public place--
on a tram, in a marketplace,
in the streets itself--
where you would fall down and
start writhing,
vomiting and excreting
rice-water stools.
This was part of the high drama
of the disease.
And the algid state would last,
if you survived,
normally from eight to
twenty-four hours.
As a patient,
you would lose--progressively
your pulse would become fainter,
or even almost absent.
The body would turn cold and
would have a livid appearance.
It looked, within a few
hours--and this was another of
the frightening aspects of this
disease--
within a few hours,
someone who had been healthy
that morning,
by the afternoon looked
cadaverized,
like a person who had been
wasting away from a long-term
wasting illness.
The breath would turn cold.
The hands would look like
dishwater hands.
And very distressing,
there would be a very severe
cramping;
terrible cramps,
terrible abdominal pain,
nausea, vomiting.
And the blood
itself--physicians who were
trying to treat patients by
bloodletting rapidly noticed
that the blood itself,
deprived of its liquid content,
was transformed into a black
tar that refused to circulate.
This could lead to heart
failure, to a terrible thirst
that the patient suffered.
And because the blood is no
longer providing adequate
oxygen,
the patient suffers--has the
sense of asphyxiating,
a terrible effort to gasping
for air.
Those are a couple of pictures
of contemporary--
I said cholera is still with
us, and so I just wanted to show
you a picture of a patient,
or another, a child patient
today.
In any case,
if the patient survived the
algid stage,
there was then the second
stage, that nineteenth-century
physicians called the reaction
stage,
that might last four or five
days.
The prognosis isn't really
better, but the symptoms are.
At this time the cold body
becomes warmer.
There's a fever usually.
The patient suffers terrible
headache and is often delirious.
The problem is that there were
terrible complications that
overtook patients in the
reaction stage.
Pneumonia was a frequent
complication.
So was kidney failure,
uremia, gangrene of the
extremities;
the ears, the nose,
fingers, toes,
the penis.
And there was a case fatality
rate then, from Asiatic cholera
in the nineteenth century,
of something like fifty
percent.
Today, as we said last time,
there is an effective oral
rehydration therapy,
and the death rate with
treatment is less than two
percent today.
That's partly because of the
effectiveness of the treatment,
and partly because the El Tor
biotype is less virulent than
classic Vibrio cholerae,
of the first six pandemics.
In any case,
then, what were the effects on
a community, on a society,
of an invasion of a disease of
this type?
Was this the return of the
plague, as people speculated?
This disease seemed a little
bit to resemble that,
in terms of the terror that it
inspired, and the social chaos
it caused during an outbreak.
Now, an outbreak--let's imagine
a nineteenth-century city.
You can pick your own,
let it be London or Paris,
or perhaps Naples.
The outbreak would tend to
begin with what the
nineteenth-century medical
community termed sporadic
cholera.
By that they meant a small
trickle of cases.
These would be transmitted in a
neighborhood,
a family, a house.
The transmission might be by
contaminated clothing or bed
linen,
contaminated food,
hand to mouth transmission from
tending a patient and then not
washing the hands.
Let me give you an example from
Venice in 1885.
There was a particularly
persistent outbreak,
in a single street,
before the disease became an
epidemic in the city as a whole.
And what happened was that this
was traced to a single
restaurant,
and the proprietor was a lovely
lady who happened to be tending
to her own infant child who was
sick with cholera in an upstairs
bedroom.
She would go upstairs and tend
to him, and then she would go
back downstairs,
without washing her hands,
and prepare food for her
clientele.
And that was how the disease
was spread in a single street,
for some time.
Now, in fortunate instances,
the disease,
this outbreak,
this so-called sporadic
cholera,
would just fade away,
and the community would escape
a large-scale misfortune.
But if the Vibrio gained
access to the city's water
supply,
then the disease would flare up
with epidemic force,
and this would be what the
nineteenth century health
authorities called epidemic
cholera,
instead of sporadic.
And if you made a graph of
cases and deaths,
there'd be a sudden spike in
mortality and morbidity.
Well, what would be the likely
magnitude of the disaster that
would follow if,
let us say, a major European
city had its water supply
contaminated with cholera?
The order of magnitude would be
different from that of the
plague.
Cholera was never responsible
for the kind of demographic
catastrophe that Europe
experienced with the Black
Death,
or later invasions of bubonic
plague.
In the nineteenth century,
Europe experienced a major
population growth,
and cholera had little impact
on the population surge.
Let's take again the example of
Naples, a city famous for its
overcrowding,
its filth and its recurring
epidemics of Asiatic cholera.
Let's compare it also with an
earlier experience of bubonic
plague.
Naples experienced a terrible
epidemic of plague in 1656.
At that time the city had about
a population numbering perhaps
half-a-million people.
The state wasn't very good at
knowing exactly how many people
lived in the city,
and its statistics for
mortality are also to be taken
with a grain of salt.
But there were estimates that
as many as 300,000 people died
of bubonic plague in that single
year.
Let's compare that with cholera
in 1837.
I choose 1837 because that was
the worst epidemic of cholera
that Naples experienced.
The population at that time was
still round about half-a-million
people, but in this worst year
of Asiatic cholera,
about 12,000 people perished.
Now, I don't--after our
experience of bubonic plague--I
don't want that to be a basis
for insensitivity.
This epidemic in which 12,000
people died is a major disaster,
but it didn't have the same
long-term cultural,
philosophical and religious
impact that the plague earlier
had,
and it didn't seem to convince
people that the end of the world
had possibly arrived.
So, cholera,
compared with plague,
is less virulent.
The bodily defenses of healthy
adults are often effective.
And it doesn't have those
efficient vectors,
rats and fleas,
that enabled the plague to
reach every home.
Also, unlike the plague,
cholera didn't endure for five
centuries, returning every
generation.
Cholera first invaded Europe in
the 1830s,
and by the 1860s the history of
cholera in the industrially
advanced nations of Northern
Europe was largely over.
And for Western Europe as a
whole, the 1890s mostly marked
the end, and 1911 certainly did.
So, cholera had only six
pandemic waves that ever invaded
Europe,
and each wave was less
widespread and claimed fewer
victims than the ones preceding
it.
That's a very different history
than the history of bubonic
plague.
How long would an epidemic last?
It would normally last,
in a great European city,
for the length of the warm
summer and perhaps the early
fall.
It would then recede and fade
away with the onset of cool
weather.
Now, why would it fade away?
Well, Robert Koch,
who discovered the Vibrio
cholerae,
said himself that this was
something,
a question to which he couldn't
give a satisfactory answer.
He said that this was one of
the great cholera mysteries,
as he called it.
But we can speculate with
regard to certain factors that
seem important.
One would be a change in
weather.
Cold dry weather is hard on the
delicate Vibrio cholerae.
Like plague,
cholera too in Europe had a
very pronounced seasonality.
It struck during the warm
months.
Another factor is that after
the disease had struck those
people who were most at risk
because of their occupations,
and their personal
susceptibility and their living
conditions,
the epidemic was then like a
fire that ran short of fuel.
It ran short of people who were
most susceptible and at high
risk.
And then communities,
also--and this was probably
important--
adopted measures of
self-defense,
and those too helped to cut
short the outbreak,
especially later in the century
when the disease was better
understood.
It's now known too that the
cholera can survive in a spore
form,
in algae blooms offshore of the
great port cities,
and so there is a possibility
too that the disease was
re-imported from the waters
offshore.
In any case,
what were the reactions to
cholera in a community?
Here there was an analogy,
possibly with plague,
in that cholera too generated
terror and fear.
This is partly because of the
agonizing nature of the symptoms
of this disease.
And the fact was that the
symptoms of cholera suggested
were analogous to something that
people were already familiar
with, and that is poisoning.
The symptoms of cholera had
symptoms that resembled someone
who had taken strychnine,
for example--rat poisoning.
And, so, people were suspicious
that perhaps this might be a
crime, rather than a natural
event.
Let me show you some images
that convey the sense of terror
that people felt at the time.
This is King Cholera;
we've said that's one of the
terms that it was associated
with.
And you can see King Cholera
astride the globe.
This is clearly a sense of its
pandemicity.
Or we can look at--this is New
York City, with cholera
approaching.
And again you can see the kind
of terror that was associated
with it.
Or let's look as well--and you
can see cholera striding over
the defensive bulwarks.
Those are the kinds of--this is
clearly one of the early
pandemics,
and what you can see is the
attempt to control this disease
with the plague measures.
You can see the troops,
sanitary cordons and all the
rest, trying to keep out
"the monster,"
as it was called.
But those in fact turned out,
for reasons we'll be coming to,
to be entirely ineffective in
dealing with cholera,
unlike the plague.
Or we can see--and here the
analogy in people's minds that
this might be the return of the
plague is clear,
because here we can see the
Grim Reaper,
with his scythe,
mowing down the whole
population.
Or here we can see,
once again in the nineteenth
century, a revival here.
This is the danse
macabre, with death calling
people.
And there you can see again the
Danse Macabre.
Here's the invitation of death
to come dance.
So, those are sorts of graphic
illustrations of the kind of
fear that this disease caused.
Well it also caused
scapegoating.
Imagine, for example--let's go
back to the first arrival of
cholera in the 1830s.
In 1830, let's think of the
Russian Empire.
When cholera struck St.
Petersburg in 1830,
at that time Russia was at war
with Poland,
and Russians believed at the
time that the disease was an act
of terror by Polish agents.
So cholera gave rise to
manhunts or witch-hunts,
find--the search for
scapegoats.
Foreigners, gypsies,
someone newly arriving in town
could be suspicious and
therefore could be set upon and
attacked, as a scapegoat.
Cholera also led,
because of its fear,
to mass flight,
and some cities experienced
almost Biblical exoduses,
with tens-of-thousands of
people evacuating cities in fear
for their lives.
And just as in Defoe's account,
it was the wealthier classes
who could afford the journey and
had somewhere to go who went
first.
A consequence would be that the
administration and public
services, in the city that was
being evacuated,
were in chaos.
Businesses shut down.
There was mass unemployment.
There was hunger and shortages
of all kinds.
There was also a new strain on
class relationships.
Cholera was a class disease,
I would argue,
in that it caused a sharply
unequal burden of death and
suffering.
Unlike plague,
unlike smallpox,
cholera primarily chose the
poor.
Now, there are reasons,
in terms of risk factors,
that explain that difference.
There was normally by this time
a pattern of housing
segregation;
that is to say,
the poor and the wealthy didn't
live next to one another,
and the poor suffered from
overcrowding,
filth, poor diet,
lack of light,
and the wells they drank from
were not the same as those used
by the wealthy.
A good example of this
difference, and one that caused
sinister speculations.
In time of plague,
as you know,
those who tended the plague
victims--physicians and
priests--perished in
unimaginable proportions.
During the time of cholera,
however,
doctors and priests moved among
the most sordid slums,
and yet mysteriously they
managed to stay healthy,
for the most part,
while those around them fell
ill and died.
There are good epidemiological
reasons for this.
Doctors didn't eat and sleep in
the sickrooms,
as the poor did.
They had better diets.
They washed their hands.
They drank different water.
But to the urban poor,
the immunity of the wealthier
classes was highly suspicious.
It suggested to some the idea
of poisoning;
particularly since the poor in
the nineteenth century weren't
medicalized.
That is to say,
they had little contact and
experience with medical
attention.
And, so, an effect,
during the cholera years,
was often violence.
There were assaults on doctors.
In some places crowds invaded
hospitals and lazarettos.
And the suspicions weren't all
in one direction.
The wealthy,
at this time in the nineteenth
century,
had a fear of those they called
the "dangerous
classes,"
and they were thinking of the
dangerous classes as dangerous
politically--
this was the rebellious
century--dangerous morally and
in religious terms.
But also they now seemed to be
dangerous medically.
And I think this is a factor in
some of the extreme violence
that one sees in 1848,
for example,
or in the Paris Commune.
There was a strain on social
relationships.
Well, what happened in terms of
public policy and organized
effects?
The first thing that happened
was a tendency to revive the
plague measures,
to contain it.
Cholera put unprecedented
pressure on authorities to do
something, to take some sort of
effective action.
And it was then that the states
responded--
first off, Russia,
Austria, Prussia,
for example--by reviving the
plague regulations:
land-based and maritime
quarantine,
sanitary cordons, lazarettos.
One can see this in pictures.
This is a cholera lazaretto.
Or one can see here is cholera,
the Vibrio arriving,
and you can see that the Board
of Health is trying to stop it,
and there are sanitary cordons
and all the rest.
This is a depiction of the
early outbreak.
Or the attempt--this is
familiar to you from time of
plague--to purify the atmosphere
by burning sulfur and with fire.
These were--or there were
funeral regulations.
And you can see here again the
people bring out your dead,
and transporting the victims to
the cemetery for rapid,
hasty burial,
the funeral regulations.
The results then were to
maximize terror,
economic disruption and flight.
The plague regulations against
cholera caused political
effects.
But they were
counter-productive in terms of
the disease, for they taught a
dangerous lesson,
that outsiders could be
dangerous.
And so we see then,
they don't stop the cholera.
They don't stop the cholera
because they're asymptomatic
carriers,
because the flight of
population causes--
trying to escape the plague
measures disperses the disease.
Because cholera can flow in
rivers and waterways,
past the troops who are trying
to contain it.
So, the plague measures weren't
effective against cholera.
But I'm going to argue what
were the long-term effects.
And I'm running rapidly out of
time, but just say that there
were, I would argue,
not just immediate drama,
there were long-term effects.
Cholera led to a big debate in
the medical profession about
contagionism,
rapid or not.
It led to the development of
epidemiology as a medical
discipline.
It contributed to the coming of
the germ theory of disease.
In terms of public health,
it led to a new set of measures
of sanitary improvement,
that we'll be talking about
next time,
and even to the refitting and
sanitary revolution in cities,
and even the rebuilding of
places like Paris and Naples;
although cholera was not the
only in fact in places like
Paris.
And it caused a mortality
revolution in urban cities.
We'll be talking more about
that.
There are reasons then to say
that although cholera caused
many of the immediate effects of
terror,
like the plague,
it didn't lead to the same kind
of mortality,
and it didn't have the same
long-term consequences.
But it did have a number of
long-term consequences that I
think it's well to bear in mind.
This was the great dreaded
disease of the whole of the
nineteenth century.